how did you guys find the shows dude it
was crazy because it's like I think you
know after we did the America shows we
obviously with an American crowd right
like we knew they were going to be Rowdy
because they're [__] Americans yeah
the Americans will chip anything they
will cheer for literally anything and
they did and so like you know our
producers were saying like oh you know
especially up in like Scandinavia but a
lot of parts of Europe they might be a
little more reserved so it might be some
quieter show so you're gonna maybe
require a little bit more riling up of
the crowd to really get them into the
the move
um but no uh I I think just our fans are
just [__] wild
anywhere in the world because so we were
warned before by our like tour staff
that you know we should expect kind of
more of more reserved crowd especially
in like the Scandinavian countries where
you know they have this kind of like
philosophy I can't remember I think it's
like the law of jonte or something where
you know it's it's kind of like they
have to be think that they're not better
than anyone and be like like humble
right very humble yeah
um they well some of the like the
European crowd I we did not have a
single choir crowd everyone was like on
average I think they were louder than
the Americans yeah
sorry Americans actually I think the
Europeans were actually louder I don't
know if it's just because they had like
one night just to really let loose and
let it go I I think it's because like
you know in America you have such a
vast choice of options it's like
somebody's into more Niche Hobbies like
anime or gaming to kind of have
opportunities to really uh express
yourself go to events with like-minded
people uh and feel like you're in a
comfortable space people to like Express
and yeah a little wild and I think going
to Europe and kind of bringing this show
format and what we talk about we have
like a [__] 10 minute segment on
hentai like I think like no other show
is doing that obviously in in
Scandinavian so I think it's like it's
kind of like a fun vibe where it's like
[__] yeah I can just [__] like what
watch a show from something I would
never get to watch I think it's also due
to the fact that you know like I think
that the main consensus is like oh
there's always like tools and like shows
and stuff like that in America right
because that's like the Hub to do shows
like that yeah very rarely do like you
know YouTubers or like any kind of like
stage shows actually do tours in Europe
so like the few times that it does
happen everyone gets hyped up I know
because it's exactly the same in
Australia right like every time I say
like a famous artist that's doing like a
world tour and they're not stopping in
Australia I'm just like what the [__]
this is [__] because when they do
come to Australia it is hype as [__] so
I totally get it yeah I mean I also
think uh so there's a big drinking
culture in Europe as well yes uh and one
thing I found funny was when we
performed in the Apollo uh in England it
was the only venue we've ever done where
we had it was contractual for us to take
a 20-minute intermission now you might
be wondering why do we need to take a 20
minute intermission what's up what's up
with that why is it on the contract well
it's so that people can go out and buy
drinks that is the most British thing
I've ever heard in my life now guys guys
you need to stop the show so people can
get more [__] pissed yeah yeah they
need they need some time to top up yeah
not even Ireland did that yeah not even
Ireland did that yeah yeah but Ireland
they pre-load it so they everyone would
come in
yeah there's one dude Rock someone for
guinnesses sits down and he's like I'm
ready
for your mates he's like no for me it's
like damn boys committed because he's
timed it out yeah I feel like the
speedrun every 30 minutes yeah yeah he
had like two in the VIP and then in
during VIP he he went out and got four
so he had six guinnesses
I remember he asked his question and
then the moment he was finished he was
like all right I'm gonna head out yeah
yeah
what do you think was the rowdiest crowd
of all of them uh also it does the what
I realized is that absolutely the day of
the week very much to talk very much if
it's a Saturday obviously can be a lot
louder and after Monday it's gonna be a
lot quieter but yeah you still get a I
think the one that sticks out to me the
most was probably the Germany show yeah
I think uh I think I think the one in uh
London obviously had an advantage
because it was the biggest show we'd
ever done by a thousand like by about
like 1 500 people I think uh but I think
in terms of like average person being
the loudest uh it's probably the Germans
yeah so loud I think Rotterdam was
pretty damn loud
Amsterdam was loud Amsterdam was also
allowed in Sweden yeah yeah like like we
said we didn't have a quiet show there
was no choir show that was loud uh or
[__] you you got like uh uh you lost
your hearing at the end of the show that
was kind of it um but one thing I liked
about show is that you know we do this
show and we get to learn a little bit
about our countries as well and I think
Alex our content producer killed it
because of the first game we you know we
had a bunch of questions related yes
during the uh trash taste uh America
Tour that we released it's kind of a
similar format but we changed the first
game yep
um to kind of focus more on what the
place is the country that we're in and
we found out what people got uh
patriotic about yeah uh the biggest
cheer in the German show uh was finding
out that they have a childhood mascot
which is like a depressed piece of bread
they lost it they were wild yeah it
wasn't burnt dust Bros yeah but dust
broth or something like that offset they
[__] lost it yeah oh my God it's
Birds
I've never seen people react to a
childhood mascot they're violently I've
never seen a childhood mascot that looks
like that looks like this as well of
course it's German
because I used to go to when I was
growing up my dad worked in Germany a
lot so I'd go to Germany all the time
and I remember whenever we used to go to
any of the like middle European
countries they always had the [__]
ugliest cartoons always the ugliest
cartoons and look at this [__]
horrific thing could you imagine looking
at this be like oh yes my childhood
the bread with warts I just like with
warts in a universe
they designed him with like the most
atrocious eye bags possible this is a
man who's watched NTR and has lived to
see another day you know look at that
[__] yeah that's so gross um I found out
you know as a Brit what US Brits get the
most patriotic about uh it's not
football it's not football yeah uh it's
when Henry the Hoover got shown
on screen and got a standing ovation
yeah dude Henry the Hoover
what was your reaction to seeing uh or
did you even know what uh what Henry was
no when it came up no I didn't like I
for one I'd never seen it before I think
I said in the show it looks like the
[__] thing in Teletubbies that feeds
them the the costume
yeah but then it was [__] wild
because that night when we got back to
the hotel uh there was a dude vacuuming
and it was [__] Henry's and it had
the name Henry on it and I'm just like
oh my gosh this is actually everywhere
if you want a vacuum that doesn't break
the Henry on yeah that like no tourists
are being did you guys have a Henry yeah
I did but then you kind of yeah this is
a classic video
for like being very good but they'd
often lose suction after a while but
it's it's the one Hoover you normally
see in uh every like establishment has
one
um most uni poles have on because it's
like pretty cheap compared to like other
vacuum cleaners as well and uh I didn't
realize this until going living outside
of the UK that I've only seen it in the
UK yeah and you don't notice it but once
once you point it out you realize oh you
see Henry everywhere everywhere yeah
yeah it's crazy because even like there
was a lot of people who went to our show
who flew in from abroad or something and
they were like I was so confused and
then I saw so many posts and replies to
my Twitter thread being like holy [__] I
see Henry in my [__] hotel oh my God
he's right there that follows me yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
is a is it is it Hetty uh his wife yeah
I couldn't think of a better name oh my
God your whole family oh there is a
Harry oh my God I didn't know so I was
right yeah so you won't even see the red
one though yeah you see the red one so
uh we are so the question was on uh on
the stage of the show uh what was the
name of this British icon yeah and for
some reason Joey answers Harry yeah so I
didn't know there was a Harry Potter
technically I got it right no no you
said Norman oh yeah he was going to say
Harry but I was like no that's dumb
yeah and we felt like it's it's so it's
so weird uh funny all about other
different cultures as well we found out
that uh the Dutch have like their own
ticks they're like
right they you know like teachers don't
do like this got a [__] massive cheer
but yeah I didn't know they don't have
their own like a tick is too much effort
apparently no it's too little it's too
little actually they needed to it's
really extravagant swirl yeah yeah it
looks like a really fancy end sign it's
like yeah yeah yeah yeah I can't
remember what the exact name of it was
um but then they also we also found out
about the uh yeah that's it that's it
wow that's such a nice name
approval
yeah I don't know what how this became a
thing uh but that's that's very fancy
and uh unlocked a lot of cool memories I
love it you could call Dutch Tech
alternative with pets
I just don't like the normal ticks
alternative things
also Dutch people uh what the [__] is up
with your toilets why oh my God yeah
yeah I didn't come across so that's true
there was one at the the venue what's
the Dutch toilet okay so you know how
normally yeah that one yeah the one you
know how normally the the bowl is kind
of like water the water bowl is right
underneath your ass yeah
Dutch toys for some reason it's like
right in front of you like this yeah so
it's just like a little water slide for
your [__] yeah it's like a splashback
countermeasure no no you get you get
splashback because from the ship because
because the the ceramic is so close to
your ass that you sometimes you get
[__] splashback if it's not yeah yeah
yeah and then when you go to wipe your
ass you have to like make eye contact
with your [__] because it's just right
here
you have to risk you're above seeing
your own [__] Joe
um you know what I'm good
you know I want to look at it
and uh is it to you you inspect your
ship hi you know so the Dutch love
looking each other you should see it you
got to see it I'm sure but too quick are
we to not appreciate the wonders of
plumbing and flush it away I actually
can gauge if my [__] is good while it's
coming out I don't need to see it well
you know sometimes when it's coming out
you're like oh this is a bad one I don't
even need to see it I know that's a bad
one yeah and then sometimes it's so
clean just swish doesn't even touch the
room